uh I here's just a filler question while
I have to figure out some technical
issues
um is it the deal breaker if a guy won't
go down on you
go ahead and start with you I think so
because if they're expecting me to go
down on them I would want them to go
down on me I feel like that's important
yeah I agree completely yeah it's a
total deal breaker 100 yeah
I don't know if I would say it's a deal
breaker but I think it's extremely
important a relationship to feel
sexually comfortable with each other
especially if it's going to be like a
serious relationship
yeah I'm agreeing with Jamie 100 on that
one
definitely a deal breaker even though I
have dealt with a [__] that would not
go down on me and expected me to go down
on him
um I definitely prefer somebody that
would be willing to go down on me but
I'm not gonna like completely cut them
off straight in your mic please
I'm not going to complete it in your mic
please
I'm not gonna completely cut somebody
off if they're not trying to go down on
me but I would prefer if they did
I agree with Jamie I don't think it's a
deal breaker but I do agree with the
fact that it is pretty important I guess
yeah I'd agree with that I think that
you should always be in a relationship
with somebody who cares enough about you
to do things that you like and so if you
find that somebody will not do that
that's kind of a red flag
yeah I wouldn't say a deal breaker I
mean because I like giving head and I
like receiving it but I mean if the the
peen is good enough then sure I mean I
really don't give two [__] so yeah
um I don't really care
I mean 69 is kind of like my favorite
thing in the world so I'd be a little
bit upset I'm not gonna lie but I would
say too like I'd read everything else
and that's the only thing yeah exactly
and that's why I was like I'm not gonna
completely cut you off if like oh you
check other boxes but like if you don't
want a 69 with me I mean what the [__]
am I doing here you know
I would also argue too that I might like
if there's not enthusiasm and like if
it's really like torture for the guy
then you know it's not enjoyable yeah
as long as I come I don't give a [__]
all right I'm trying to trigger this TTS
nope okay TTS is broke typical okay uh
guys in the chat don't take advice from
any females on panel especially the O of
corn Stars they are sickness society and
why here here please Center men on the
um you need to get a passport and fly to
Argentina Argentina Colombia or South
Korea
um okay cheeks who's this who is this
directed to
um
girls
it's like ninety percent honestly in
general I don't think that like men
should really take relationship advice
from women
sexual Dynamics is that not your job
though no I don't give advice not to Men
on dating I've said multiple times it's
like a misconception
interesting I like that okay so where
would you because it's like like how
what am I going to tell a guy how to
approach a girl yeah no because I've
never approached women and you know I
think women like we don't typically like
know I mean one thing but as a woman you
know what you want yeah yeah I think you
can give like tips for what you like
what may work like the thing is like
women don't even know what we want
yeah
I'm feeling it depends on
okay
um like in what context how do you like
to be approached very confidently
it depends on the woman because if
you're going up to like a bookworm yeah
he comes over like hey you're hot as
[__] yeah you know what I mean but it
depends read the room type deal yeah how
do you like it what do you like I'm
direct I'll probably hit on the guy
first oh yeah the same I'm with Mom yeah
me as well
can I have you strain your mic please
just yeah there you go
um wait so you guys would hit on the guy
first yeah sometimes it depends on the
situation
you'd hit on a guy first yeah
yeah I was interested you've done it
before oh yeah yeah okay
and for those of you here who have hit
on the guy first generally speaking does
it go over pretty well does it works
yeah
it works for you works for you like you
don't really get rejected do you I
when you've gone up to a guy yeah how
did you get rejected
um
I'm not interested no I have a
girlfriend or just
no I'm not interested that's okay okay
especially with dancing you have to
learn how to approach men especially
when working in a club you have to learn
how to approach men and be able to come
up to them and talk to them and hit on
them first it's
is it just you two that are dancers
as well anybody dancing that's how we
used to be a dancer five years ago did
you guys ever date anyone that you met
at the club and would you never
um
I let him take me on dates but I never
did anything sexual with him and why do
you say absolutely not I just think that
if you want to have a healthy
relationship with somebody I can't speak
for everybody but I would not be okay
with my I know what goes on in the strip
club and I'm not okay with what goes on
in this trip today
the stuff with some other dancers some
dancers do extras I don't the men too
though I can't tell you how many times I
have been sitting at a table with a guy
who's just going on and on about how
much he hates his wife or his girlfriend
or whatever and that just
that's not what I want for myself and
any man that I see in the strip club
like you're there for a reason and
that's not the kind of man that I want
you still dance currently correct I do
yeah okay do you have a celebrity crush
I was gonna say if he walks into the
strip club do you do you date him but
okay
um so
really quick here who's uh who's single
show of hands
kind of ish you're kind of ish but
you're pregnant hello are you on dating
apps right now absolutely not no no
dating apps I stopped doing what I do
for work when I met the person I got
pregnant from wait hold on but so you do
traditional
I'm just [__] whatever you do
traditional porn I was doing it up until
I met this person and I was very
comfortable with them so I stopped doing
it like a week into us talking I like
stopped doing the actual
um
corn like being on a website I haven't
shot anything at all since I met him
um
so yeah
so thank you I'm so sorry no go ahead
someone who's done that before for a
partner that I met totally regret it why
did you quit porn Forum not even a man a
person honestly I just have been getting
there's been a lot of stuff in the
industry that's been going on that I was
already kind of getting tired of so I
was slowly transitioning out of it and
going more towards only fans because I
like being able to in charge and being
able to do what I want to do yeah
um so I like that so I was already kind
of getting out of it and I just really
do care and appreciate this person very
much and you know he
he didn't tell me to stop doing it but I
could tell that it made him
uncomfortable yeah they didn't ever have
to tell you yeah I could tell that it
made him uncomfortable and like I really
do care about this person I'm trying to
make it work so for now I'm not gonna be
working in the corn industry what are
your long-term goals
um so I'm starting to make better money
on only fans right now and I want to get
like Airbnb properties nice
um also I lived in Israel I served the
arm in the Army in Israel also so I do
want to go back there and like
I want to get my Nursing degree and go
back to Israel and like help out over
there oh wow yeah it's very Noble
Nick don't unstar the red chats please
you got to keep them up
here I restart it
okay
um
so okay
the guy you're currently seeing though
you're he's definitely the one that
100 this is the 100 yeah there's no way
that it's not as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible